[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va parler évidemment de politique de
la déclaration du Président de la
République hier soir qui a été vu par
cette française sur 10 c'est de dire
qu'elle était attendue des conséquences
politiques qu'on peut en attendre on
reviendra aussi sur la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et les
conséquences aussi qu'on peut en tirer
et pour parler de tout ça
Véronique Jérôme bonjour bonjour à tous
vous êtes Polito économiste et vous êtes
maître de conférence à l'Université de
Paris Saclay
Florence bercadet se crée bonjour
Patrice
et vous êtes la présidente du club des
femmes du Medef on va en parler dans un
instant Raphaël matadu vidéo bonjour
Jean-Patrice bonjour à tous droit public
à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin et alors on attend vos
éclairages justement sur le Conseil
constitutionnel
et le jeudi bonjour bonjour ça va bien
fort bien
non seulement éditeur vous êtes un
éditeur qui vient avec un livre qui
s'appelle des missiles bien sulfureuse
de Dominique bourgeon bourgeon Dominique
bourgeon
ce serait la correspondance entre
Chelsea et Mussolini ça tourne entre les
des lettres échangées entre chercher des
Mussolini avant la guerre ça sera une
correspondance qui s'arrête en 37
et où dans quelques lettres Churchill
dirait presque son admiration envers
Mussolini c'est vrai ou c'est il y a
quelques historiens on a retrouvé
quelques lettres des historiens qui dit
oui mais non pas vraiment d'autres enfin
voilà c'est un petit débat
non mais c'est c'est beaucoup plus dans
une une visée de de prévoir ce qui va se
passer après la guerre d'essayer de de
construire des choses un axes etc contre
contre l'Union soviétique contre Hitler
etc donc mais c'est tout à fait
intéressant c'était des justement que
beaucoup de gens essayent de cacher et
c'est un peu le l'essence de ce roman
policier mais pas que voilà la première
rencontre entre Mussolini et Hitler a
élu à Venise voilà mais c'est au Golfe
qui est au golf de venir
et alors et alors je rencontre ça n'a
aucun intérêt mais Hitler était fou
furieux parce qu'il avait 10 pour la
peine de s'habiller donc il était venu
en civil avec un appart des verbes tout
froissé et Mussolini était comme
d'habitude donc et en plus il ne se
comprenait pas parce que il pensait que
Mussolini parler allemand alors que
l'autre comprend rien et ça a été une
rencontre absolument terrible voilà
Hitler il parle également je crois non
oui voilà donc
c'est absolument épouvantable quand il
voulait faire
donc ça a été une rencontre voilà et
finalement il se déteste c'est assez
amusant on va parler d'autre chose que
d'Hitler du soleil de Winston Churchill
et
ben on va parler par exemple de Florence
Mercedes qui préside le club des femmes
du Medef
oui qu'est-ce que c'est ce club des
femmes c'est un club de femmes donc
il s'agit du MEDA feeling dans lequel on
a organisé et lancé ce club de femmes la
semaine dernière ça a eu beaucoup de
succès parce qu'il y avait 80 femmes qui
étaient présentes
il n'y avait que 5 hommes mais les
hommes sont parfaitement bienvenus dans
ce club oui donc en fait c'est un club
qui veut développer un certain nombre de
thématiques 1 essayer de
à la fois de promouvoir auprès des
institutions et d'inciter les
institutions à promouvoir la parité un
peu partout dans des institutions dans
les entreprises dans les associations
enfin partout
essayez d'aider les femmes dans le monde
bancaire et financier pour pouvoir
obtenir des financements dans leur
projet d'entreprise parce qu'on est
quand même donc on est axé Économie et
entreprise
faut promouvoir les un certain nombre de
métiers qui sont pas des métiers
habituels pour les femmes et on sait à
quel point par exemple le métier
d'ingénieur et masculin et que les
filles alors qu'il y a des filles qui
pourraient être parfaitement capables à
la sortie du lycée d'intégrer des
filières d'ingénieurs donc il faut
arriver à promouvoir au sein des écoles
une mixité des emplois donc il y aura
des actions au niveau des écoles il faut
accompagner la parité dans les conseils
d'administration les comités de
direction essayer aussi d'accentuer la
parité au sein des entreprises et
l'égalité salariale puisque chaque année
des entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
doivent faire un accord ou un plan
unilatéral sur l'égalité professionnelle
et on se rend compte que il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui n'ont pas ou une
mauvaise égalité professionnelle avec
des index qu'ils doivent publier chaque
année qui sont pas bons
voilà et essayer d'inciter aussi des
femmes qui sont adhérentes aux Medef
Yvelines de prendre des mandats mandats
de s'engager dans la vie associative
dans la vie politique
et puis donc voilà donc on va mettre en
œuvre un certain nombre d'actions de
réunions on va faire venir des femmes
qui ont du pouvoir entre guillemets au
sein de la France on a une marraine
nadiae qui était là voilà qui est
ancienne ministre de la Ville et qui est
actuellement député absolument donc
c'est notre Marianne elle est venue
faire un discours extrêmement chaleureux
et enthousiaste à notre club et ça a été
une ambiance assez extraordinaire et
c'est bien parti donc j'invite toutes
les femmes qui à nous rejoindre en fait
18 avril et toutes les femmes à nous
rejoindre j'espère qu'il y a plus de
monde qui vous entends que de gens qui
ont entendu de Gaulle je vous donne vu
le jeu
et quand même énorme bravo autre fait
que je voudrais qu'on commente avant de
passer à la politique c'est une décision
du référé au Tribunal Administratif sur
une demande des avocats
concernant les conditions de vie à la
prison de Bois-d'Arcy
parce que finalement c'est les avocats
qui ont
cette fonction sont
son sentiment sur le la décision du
tribunal administratif alors
effectivement il y a une réforme en
décembre 2021 qui a réformé l'article
719 du code de procédure pénale et qui
ouvre dans le cadre des visites
impromptues et inopinées comme on dit
pour les inspections du travail ou
l'URSSAF ou le fisc au sein des maisons
d'arrêt pour pouvoir
observer critiquer les conditions de vie
et les conditions de dignité quand on
lit le c'est effrayant absolument
effrayant mais ça c'est connu depuis
très longtemps puisque là il y a il y a
12 points qui sont soulevés par le
tribunal le tribunal
sportifs
exactement il y en a 12 qui sont revenus
absolument bon il constate qu'il y a
déjà par rapport au contrôle qui a eu
lieu il y a quelques années des
améliorations mais il reste quand même
des points qui sont assez inadmissibles
notamment sur les douches qui sont dans
un état complètement déplorable sur le
prison
c'est que on voit que il y a soit un des
intérêts de la part de l'État sur les
conditions de de vie des détenus au sein
des maisons d'arrêt mais quand on voit
l'état des douches quand on voit le fait
qu'il y a des cafards partout dans les
cellules et que rien n'est fait qu'il y
a des problématiques de de
les douches il y a des fuites il y a des
fenêtres qui sont pas calcuitées il y a
des cellules dans lesquelles il pleut
les détenus ont 3 mètres carrés pour
vivre au quotidien donc il y a tout un
tas de d'injonctions qui ont été faites
par le tribunal
administratifs exactement donc formation
des auxiliaires les problèmes des
douches des lavabos
des sanitaires des promenades qui ont
des politiciens aussi des
assez sales sur les problèmes de la
propreté des espaces de circulation et
un point qui est quand même assez
incroyable c'est sur les fouilles
intégrales en demandant à ce que les
fouilles
intégral soit faite dans des locaux
appropriés et non pas dans les douches
dans les parloirs ou dans des lieux où
il y a du monde donc on parle de
fouilles approfondie donc c'est pas
juste comme ça et donc ça soit fait dans
un lieu un peu privé ou il est pas tout
le monde qui regarde quoi Revel oui
alors cette ordonnance du de référer du
tribunal administratif de Versailles je
vais essayer de la mettre en à mettre en
contexte vraiment un petit peu plus
large c'est une procédure de référé
liberté c'est à dire que les avocats
mais aussi la section française de
l'Observatoire international des prisons
on saisit le tribunal administratif en
référé liberté l'objectif c'était de
mettre de demander au juge de mettre fin
en 48 heures à une atteinte
manifestement grave et illégale à une
liberté fondamentale et donc le jeu
administratif c'est a été saisi et donc
à estimer qu'il y avait cette condition
d'urgence c'est-à-dire de devoir agir et
de rendre une décision dans les 48
heures parce que un certain nombre de
liberté fondamentales ont été enfin le
tribunal qui l'a constaté sont son
violet tout simplement
je prends un certain nombre de liberté
fondamentales que le juge a soulevé le
droit à la vie le droit à la vie privée
et familiale et le droit au
à ne pas subir de traitement inhumain et
dégradant donc sur ces trois libertés
fondamentales le jeu va estimé qu'il y
avait une violation une violation ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le cette
décision elle s'inscrit dans un contexte
un petit peu plus large puisque la Cour
européenne est droit de l'homme en 2021
en 2020 pardon avait condamné la France
pour absence de recours préventif
effectif concernant les conditions
inhumaines de d'incarcération donc c'est
à dire que la Cour estimée que la France
n'avait pas de dispositif permettant aux
prisonniers de contester les conditions
dans lesquelles ils étaient incarcérés
le Conseil d'État en 2020 a répondu si
vous voulez à la cette injonction de la
Cour européenne en estimant que il
pouvait enjoindre et je pense je prends
cet exemple qui est quand même assez
extraordinaire le Conseil a en juin à
l'administration de faire en sorte que
dans les cellules où il y avait des
sanitaires communes il fallait mettre un
rideau pour perdre pour permettre
de conserver leur intimité et puis en
mars 2022 ça c'est très intéressant
le Conseil le Conseil d'État pardon
lapsus le Conseil d'État a estimé qu'il
appartenait aux demandeurs donc aux
prisonniers d'app la preuve d'apporter
la preuve que les conditions de vie
étaient indignés mais il y avait une
sorte de présomption de de fautes de la
part de l'État à charge pour l'état de
démontrer que les conditions n'étaient
pas indignes d'accord et en fait là
cette décision j'en termine cette
décision va enjoindre à l'administration
de réagir sur 12 ou 13 points et pour
essayer justement de de faire en sorte
que les conditions soient moins indignes
je rappelle juste que l'État à 15 jours
pour faire appel devant le Conseil
d'État s'il le souhaite et que on peut
imaginer on peut imaginer que dans
quelques temps ces personnes là engagent
ou essaient d'engager la responsabilité
de l'État pour faute pour justement
cette fois-ci obtenir une indemnisation
que c'était une prison qui est quand
même relativement récente en 1987
j'étais à l'école des avocats et on
pouvait faire un stage à l'extérieur et
en dehors du milieu judiciaire et j'ai
fait un stage de trois semaines à la
maison d'arrêt de Bois-d'Arcy
et
elle n'était pas dans les dans l'état
dans lequel effectivement elle est
aujourd'hui puisque j'ai pu visiter des
cellules
tout le monde s'en fout
dans l'opinion publique moi je le vois
avec
des pensées
que tous les prisonniers sont logés dans
des trucs quatre étoiles il pense qu'ils
ont la télévision que c'est la liberté
totale qui peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent etc et puis en plus ils disent
bah ils l'ont pas volé on va pas
dépenser de l'argent là-dedans donc ça
rejoint les mers qui sont tous là en
train de dire
partout
que vous avez marqué il y a quelques
années qui était le témoignage d'un chef
d'entreprise qui rentrait en prison je
sais pas si vous souvenez c'était dans
Libération et qui s'étonnait qu'on lui
donne une boîte de préservatifs
[Musique]
un peu de moments à l'accueil des des
personnes qui arrivaient en détention et
c'était une époque où il y avait eu un
très gros de bourses de grosses
poursuites contre des cadres à
Versailles je ne dirai pas d'où ça et
ils arrivaient à l'accueil de la maison
d'arrêt de Bois d'Arcy mais il savait
plus où ils étaient c'était hyper
déstabilisant ils comprenait pas ce
qu'il faisait là et c'était c'était
terrible
essentiel
parce que finalement ça ne peut que
entretenir la haine qui peut avoir
derrière les barreaux déjà j'imagine que
et pas toujours compris la sanction
n'est pas toujours comprise mais de
surprendre
mais en sortant on a envie de se venger
aussi si on a eu des conditions des plus
rapides
la carcération de beaucoup de colle
blanc même de politique
le flop présent c'est un petit passage
de la santé la nuit par les mecs qui
hurlent parce qu'ils sont violés Java
c'est vrai que c'était quand même
absolument un témoignage voilà on s'est
dit bah oui c'est pas c'est pas un petit
voyou de banlieue qui est en train de
nous dire que c'est horrible non là
c'est un mec qui sait ce que c'est que
la vie etc
on parle de politique et bon il y avait
le donc l'intervention télévisée du
président de la République hier et la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
Macron peut-il reprendre la main
[Musique]
alors
allocution avec trois points essentiels
on y reviendra peut-être
100 jours les 100 jours pour pour
changer les choses pour changer la donne
c'était un peu ça le taux de la
l'intervention
et puis des réactions auxquelles on
pouvait s'attendre c'est-à-dire on
pourrait écrire les choses à l'avant ça
peut mais non pas tout à fait parce que
c'est assez rare de dans ma bouche de
dire du bien de quelqu'un de la CGT mais
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT
qui a dit oui le président Macron a dû
écrire son truc avec chasse gipiti son
discours
sans aucune sans aucune âme enfin moi
c'est pas ce que j'attends la président
de la République il nous avait déjà
appris nous laver les mains et à ouvrir
les fenêtres maintenant il nous parle
des appareils auditifs je veux dire
c'est passionnant mais est-ce que c'est
commentaire qui disent ah mais voilà
c'est pas assez concret si il fait dans
le concret on n'a pas besoin d'un
secrétaire d'État au budget on a besoin
d'un président de la République alors à
un moment c'est quand même compliqué un
peu de souffle d'un peu de grandeur d'un
peu de direction
etc c'est pas c'est pas des c'est pas
important je sais pas je peux pas faire
de l'avocat du diable comme on disait je
m'en fous des appareils auditifs enfin
je veux dire c'est c'est pas le problème
du président de la République enfin
j'espère
qu'il fixe un cap qui qui donne des
choses enfin qui qui soit là il y a un
quartier essentiel de base je pense de
presque j'ai trouvé c'est en effet quand
il parle du travail c'est le plein
d'emploi parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il considère que le plein emploi
c'est ce qu'on considérait d'ailleurs
c'est prédécesseurs aussi ils ont pas
réussi forcément enfin ni ni Sarkozy ni
Hollande niveau ici ils ont ils ont
perdu quand ils sont représentés c'est
la lutte contre le chômage
que ça facilite contre le chômage parce
qu'il est vrai que dans les
modélisations politiques ou économiques
on a l'habitude de faire nos Jérôme on
s'est rendu compte que c'était une des
variables clés qui explique la
reconduction d'un sortant ou pas parce
qu'on regarde de sorte c'est celui qui
agitée
mais là la question du chômage est un
peu moins prégnante à partir du moment
où l'inflation est revenue au galop on a
on avait perdu l'habitude de penser à
l'inflation de penser au prix et là
aujourd'hui la priorité des Français
c'est la lutte contre l'inflation donc
il y a peut-être sur le chômage et
peut-être pas la bonne variable je sais
peut-être pas le bon argument deuxième
point la lutte contre l'inflation le
pouvoir d'achat c'est très gentil mais
ça n'a pas n'appartient pas à l'état de
décider des salaires du privé donc là
forcément il y a une injonction mais
elle n'est pas obligatoire
non mais intéressant de laisser
justement la main ou partenaire sociaux
dire c'est au syndicat et au patronat de
se mettre d'accord on montre un câble
mais par le passé il y avait aussi un
effet de démonstration de la part du
public c'est-à-dire que le public
faisait grève par procuration pour le
privé qui ne pouvait pas le public
augmenter salaire le privé se sentait
obligé de rattraper là le public ne peut
plus montrer l'exemple en tout cas en
matière de salaire salaire des
fonctionnaires c'est pas ce qui augmente
le plus le plus souvent et plus
rapidement donc enfin il me semble on
est d'accord et et donc ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas une référence en
la matière même si le statut du
fonctionnaire est particulier dans le
statut du fonctionnaire je crois que
l'enrichissement est noté comme n'étant
pas un élément donc on a bien compris
qu'un fonctionnaire n'était pas là pour
s'enrichir il est là au service de
l'intérêt général mais il y a quand même
matière à demander une rémunération mais
pour revenir à Emmanuel Macron je vais
faire comme je fais avec les étudiants
qui font une soutenance orale d'un
mémoire je commence par les bons points
ça va très vite pour pouvoir garder du
temps pour dire ce qui te pose problème
le bon point je l'ai trouvé apaiser à
s'agit en tout cas il y a pas il y avait
pas la
revanche
et là je pense que étant donné le
personnage on peut imaginer qu'il a fait
de gros efforts pour essayer de rester
je dirais un minimum dans l'empathie
peut-être pas mais d'aller vers cet
élément là donc ça c'est important de
voir quelqu'un qui s'est assagi et qui
vient pas rajouter à la colère le
reconnais d'ailleurs la colère et
reconnait la colère il n'a pas présenté
l'excuse mais est-ce que c'est un
président de la République de présenter
des excuses personnellement je pense que
non parce que s'il commence à présenter
des excuses
mais certains attendaient de donc là on
peut considérer que il a pris ses
décisions en connaissance de cause et
c'est tant mieux parce que la moindre le
moindre retour est de présentation de de
remords etc ça affecté sa crédibilité si
on regarde la popularité à moins de 30 %
c'était pas l'occasion de de la réduire
encore plus par contre sur le sur le
fond et sur la forme les points qui sont
plus négatifs c'est cette impression de
faire
sur place en avançant d'appuyer sur le
frein sur l'accélérateur en même temps
on nous dit qu'on va prendre le temps
d'avancer prendre le temps d'accélérer
donc moi c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
d'imaginer comment on peut faire ces
deux choses en même temps il donne des
Caps mais là où les je pense que les des
attentes sur le concret c'était de
savoir comment quelle réforme il faut
réformer bien sûr la justice éducation
la santé les transports tous ces aspects
là mais comment le fait-on l'intention
est même l'intention du plein emploi on
sait très bien qu'elle passe par
différentes
ressources je dirais à la limite on
double encore plus c'est des contrats
aidés et on fait baisser le chômage mais
ça c'est pas viable c'est pas c'est de
l'employabilité mais c'est pas de
l'emploi on donne la possibilité d'homme
et quelqu'un qui sort d'un apprentissage
maintenant je fais quoi si la boîte je
suis ne le prends pas ça a marché
c'est de la poursuite c'est
l'accompagnement ensuite qui est pas
toujours évident quand on a des
apprentis en Master et aucun problème
les entreprises courent après les
étudiants quand c'est dans d'autres le
secteur c'est un peu plus compliqué et
puis pour ne pas être trop longue je
pense que les 100 jours c'est une c'est
une erreur parce que intervenir pour
dire on s'attend à des réponses et pour
dire mais attendez je vais réfléchir je
donne encore 100 jours alors que la
première ministre avait eu son a
finalement pas la même interprétation
que vous je pense que il a parlé de
réponse concrètes et donc ils feront un
bilan dans les 100 jours de ce que nous
avons c'est qu'on a pas c'est le le le
carnet avec les différentes étapes la
feuille de route est pas très claire
alors bien sûr c'est la première
ministre qui est chargée de mettre les
choses en musique mais c'est un peu
c'est un peu
confusion
mais en même temps pouvait-il en changer
je pense pas que ce c'était une bonne
idée
[Musique]
le problème c'est c'est ça c'est que lui
il veut passer à autre chose et puis on
voit bien dans les réactions notamment
des syndicats il y a ceux qui restent
bloqués sur la réforme de retraite et
avoir un 1er mai d'ailleurs ce qui sera
sans doute très fort dans la
protestation c'est ça passer à autre
chose mais avec qui quoi c'est ça avec
qui j’écoutais hier justement la
secrétaire général de la CGT qui
expliquait que revenir à la table et
négociations c'était impossible tant que
la réforme n'était pas n'était pas
retirée donc là c'était pour l'instant
en tout cas c'est vraiment une fin de
nous recevoir la vraie question c'est
effectivement avec qui et comment
gouverner et je rejoins un Véronique sur
sur toute son analyse et je rajouterai
un point ce qui a manqué hier Emmanuel
Macron dans son dans son allocution de
mon point de vue c'est le mode d'emploi
c'est justement comment va-t-il faire
parce qu'il a dit je j'attends les
partenaires sociaux on va faire on va on
va se concerter on va négocier mais sur
quelle base sur quel principe sur quel
indicateur sur quels objectifs et dans
quelle dispositif dans quel système et
en fait moi ce qui me de mon point de
vue d'institutionnalistes ce qui me ce
qui m'a gêné ce qui m'a frustré
finalement c'est le fait de ne pas
savoir comment il va faire
est-ce que ce sont des États généraux
des Grenelles des concertations est-ce
que il va mettre en place des
dispositifs de peut-être alors on va en
reparlera après mais d'autres référendum
j'en sais rien je sais pas est-ce qu'il
va après changer de d'orientation
politique est-ce qu'il va plus se
diriger vers la droite plus faire le
centre gauche je n'en sais rien personne
ne le sait et finalement c'est ça qui
manquait Jean-Charles tout à l'heure
parler de souffle et en fait moi c'est
ce que j'attendais j'attendais un cap
j'attendais un nouveau souffle et
d'expliquer aux Français comment il
allait alors on change jour ou en 220
enfin pour le coup ça m'est égal
complètement mais comment est-ce qu'il
allait concevoir l'exercice du pouvoir
après cette séquence qui est quand même
assez
c'est terrible il y a peut-être aussi
voilà une sorte de délai qui va jusqu'au
14 juillet et voilà de voir s'il peut
reprendre la main il faut aussi regarder
comment ça se passe Florence matador
alors j'ai à peu près une analyse
comme d'autres grands et bien non
professeur de droit constitutionnel mais
j'étais effectivement déçue parce que
tous les points qu'il a soulevé en
disant voilà les chantiers que je vais
ouvrir l'école l'hôpital
etc ce sont des chantiers dont ils
parlent depuis 2017 en disant on va
renforcer la justice on va donner des
moyens la justice on va donner des
moyens à l'école on va donner à des
moyens aux hôpitaux
mais oui mais il en parle depuis 2017 et
on a l'impression que et là il dit bah
on va ouvrir comme si c'était une
nouveauté alors c'est pas une nouveauté
c'est quelque chose qui existe même sur
les les précédents
il y a le travail d'un côté mais je
parle des autres points donc ça on en
parle de et on se dit bah oui mais alors
qu'est-ce qui a été fait alors il fait
il aurait dû peut-être valorisé ce qu'il
y a déjà été fait pour dire qu'on
poursuit ces chantiers là on a
l'impression qu'ils ouvrent donc là je
trouve qu'ils ça manque effectivement de
souffler de hauteur de vue après sur le
chantier de droit du travail qui
m'intéresse particulièrement ce que je
regrette c'est que ce chantier aurait dû
avoir lieu avant la réforme des
retraites puisque c'est là
la problématique des seniors etc je
pense que la réforme des retraites
serait beaucoup mieux passée
et que ça a été fait à l'envers et je
suis pas sûr si je pense que il y avait
eu des solutions par rapport
au Seigneur
mais je pense qu'ils avaient
parfaitement raison n'était pas à un an
pour faire la réforme des traites alors
elle a été faite en 2024 je pense ça
aurait pas changé le cours du monde par
rapport à la problématique
de financement de la retraite juste pour
revenir ce que sur ce que vous disiez
enfin il y a la première ministre qui
est chargée de d'expliquer comment
peut-être par quelle voix est moyen on
va on va
terminer
donc je crois qu'elle devrait le fait
parce que j'ai compris le faire assez
vite oui mais dans le régime actuel
primauté de la République c'est vrai
qu'on s'attend on s'attendrait même tous
finalement on critique mais on s'attend
si à ce que le président de la
République prennent peut-être plus de
place et de
je reviens sur ce que je disais ça
manque de souffle ça manque de projet ça
manque de on a je pense que c'est dans
une période relativement troublée où on
sent que les crispations se font de plus
en plus fortes un peu partout je pense
qu'on a envie d'un homme d'État qui
prennent toute sa place et là j'avais
vraiment l'impression d'avoir une sorte
de de Premier ministre alors comme on en
a
[Musique]
ils avaient borne bon bah ouais
comment on est contradictoire prend
cette posture là on dit comment il
Jupiter rien il est méprisant
en démocratie quand même on se dit ça
parce que il est comme ça depuis 2017 et
que les gens
monarchistes qui reg ent là-bas
il y a pas eu de résultats donc à partir
du moment où il y a pas de résultats
donc il y a plus de gens qui sont
contents que de gens satisfaits
quand vous êtes élus il est avec quoi
27% au premier tour donc une année 22
aujourd'hui je n'en perd pas beaucoup
non mais c'est pas ça l'idée c'est que
normalement le politique se fait élire
avec un projet avec l'ambition de
changer les choses à partir du moment où
on vote pour lui c'est qu'on adhère à ce
projet donc sur la réforme des retraites
il y a eu toutes ces ambiguïtés de dire
finalement
son projet
ils adoraient
de l'élection présidentielle c'est pour
ça que ça ne nécessite pas à rassembler
comme il le ferait et pour avoir une
imagerie majorité mais surtout pour une
fois qu'un homme politique fait ce
pourquoi elle a été élue enfin je veux
dire il a été élu en annonçant la
retraite à 65 ans alors il a il l'a
proposé de 64 c'est quand même
merveilleux
formidable et hier c'était sur France
Culture avec une collègue à vous qui est
très bonne constitution je crois que la
présidente d'association des
constitutionnalistes mais il y avait
Charles de souverain c'est ça qui dit
qui disait parler parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y a ce sondage sur la démocratie
qui dit que les gens n'ont plus
confiance de leurs hommes politiques il
dit oui mais c'est tout à fait normal
parce que
ne supporte plus le moindre truc
démocratique direction là mais même
Laurent Berger qui parle de casser la
baraque qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce
que c'est
beaucoup plus parce que
négociations
c'est que j'appelle les Français a
casser la baraque le premier mec même si
c'est peut-être une image
totalement désastreux
quand même c'est une image désastreuse
vous disiez des perspectives politiques
alors il y avait il y avait un article
du jour du dimanche qui qui était dit
très pour Macron ici de secours est à
droite
est-ce que c'est alors on parle
d'ailleurs de de premier possible alors
on parle de Rachida Dati
et demandez de Catherine votre train de
Catherine Vautrin qui revient et il y a
et même de députés qui alors évidemment
le maire d'armanin et il y a aussi le
nom de du député qui serait LR
compatible qui est hors berger
[Musique]
quel est l'intérêt de finir à droite
pour pour Macron la France est à droite
donc et puis c'est bien quand même de
temps en temps de faire des choix mais
justement
rien contre reberger mais on voit un peu
les limites avec le président Macron
certains jaunissent mais d'un certain
manque d'expérience est-ce que ce serait
la bonne personne ça fait deux premiers
ministres alors deuxième mandaté le
groupe renaissance après c'est plus un
gouvernement c'est une garderie faut
arrêter de dire non mais est-ce qu'on
peut de temps en temps avoir des gens
avec un peu d'expérience face à ça ça
serait quand même le minimum on a on
voit bien que c'est ce qui manque aussi
à Macron quoi ce type est qui est arrivé
enfin je veux dire il arrive le
Président il connaît peu autre chose
enfin je veux dire on voit ces bourdes à
l'international enfin d'équivalent dans
un équivalence dans un pays il est là
c'est c'est presque un déclencheur de
guerre
voilà donc moi j'aimerais le retour des
hommes d'expérience des hommes ou des
femmes bien évidemment
je ne dis pas oui pour l'instant mais
pour l'instant parce qu'il veut un
contrat il veut un programme de votre
ami Pérou aussi qui grimpe derrière la
porte un peu toujours
de la République
non mais il faut quelqu'un de
fédérateurs et c'est très compliqué de
trouver aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui est un
peu
totalement divisée qu'il est qu'il est
en fin de vie quel est l'intérêt de
parle pas ils sont tellement
discréditifs
avec un groupe en famille quoi
vous avez 10 ans qui luttait pour la
retraite à 65 ans et il ne vote pas
c'est très fort mais c'est une honte
absolue
l'intérêt c'est peut-être de trouver une
majorité c'est trouver une majorité et
pour la fin de mois relative plus stable
je pense je pense que je pense que du
côté de l'air c'est plus stable plus
discipliné que de l'autre côté voilà
après il peut y avoir après mais est-ce
qu'il pourrait pas y avoir une alliance
plus forte avec on voit bien que il y a
dans l'Ariège et une élection avec une
socialiste non anti-up qui a été élu
Cazeneuve est en train de
rarement entendu des mots aussi violents
sur Mélenchon et sur la fille que ceux
de Cazeneuve donc il y a peu de ici
comme jusqu'ici Macron avait une jambe
droite et une jambe gauche il y a
peut-être aussi quelques quelques
éléments Manuel Valls avait fait un très
très bon papier d'ailleurs
intervention devant
[Musique]
Espagne parfois
de lui en tant que personnalité mais il
avait fait je trouve un très bon à pied
sur un contrat de gouvernement qui
serait possible et qui a dirait un peu
des personnalités moins des parties que
des personnalités d'ailleurs le problème
au début
c'était très intéressant
pardon oui
en fait je suis d'accord sur la
nécessité de trouver un majorité une
majorité après c'est vrai qu'on voit que
il faut aller chercher une majorité à
chaque projet de loi ça va être ça va
être ce qu'il faudrait c'est se mettre
d'accord sur 4 ou 5 points essentiels
nucléaire vous avez l'éducation vous
avez
quatre ou cinq sujets sur lesquels ils
ont relativement les sujets dont il a
parlé hier ça devrait faire ça devrait
réunir bien sûr ça fera peut-être ça
fait 6 ans et demi qu'on attend un
discours de du président sur
l'immigration par exemple
c'est repousser c'est la loi va être
maintenant débiter en tranches
d'immigration
une obsession de l'immigration
l'idée c'est de faire le lit de
l'extrême droite c'est ce qu'on peut
continuer à dire que c'est pas un sujet
évidemment qui qui complique c'est que
il ne peut pas se représenter oui
justement on pourrait même imaginer un
peu en faisant de la politique fiction
qu'il est l'intérêt de la France
chevillé au corps que finalement il
fasse des mesures en ayant que faire de
sa popularité d'ailleurs il l'avait il
l'avait dit il avait dit je ne regarde
pas les cours de popularité on n'est pas
obligé de croire parce que il paraît que
François Mitterrand avait dans sa poche
de veston à l'intérieur moi aussi je
vous raconte une histoire mais j'ai
raconté très mal une pochette au monde
pensait que c'était un très gros
portefeuille et c'était les derniers
sondages donc ne quittez jamais les
sondages donc
voilà regarde jamais les sondages
ça lui donne une plus grande liberté de
manœuvre une plus grande marge de
manœuvre on peut aussi imaginer quand
même qu'il
met des appétit qui se font derrière et
aussi je me pose la question de savoir
quel intérêt pour une force d'opposition
la droite en l'occurrence pour un membre
de LR alors même si on peut dire LR
qu'est-ce que ça représente en temps
aujourd'hui oui mais il y a encore deux
droites donc de toute façon ça s'appelle
LR ou autre il y a quand même encore des
je pense une partie d'électorat qui a
envie de voter à droite et considérant
cela quel intérêt pour quelqu'un qui se
dit de droite d'aller porter secours un
président qui est un peu en dérive pour
finalement
redorer non pas son blason mais son son
bilan et faire qu'au final il fasse
ça c'est de se porter secours à soi-même
oui non non le
en sortant à sortir victorieux être
réélu ou à faire élire un membre de
l'opposition alors que normalement le
jeu de la politique est quand même assez
assez
cruels la prochaine présidentielle oui
mais elle a l'air de toute façon dit
comme ça personne ne peut y croire mais
on peut imaginer qu'il y ait d'autres
ambitions qui puisse se former et
rassembler et que d'une certaine façon
je pense que sur le sur le sur la
réforme des retraites l'avoir soutenu au
seul motif qu'on avait à la même idée 10
DLR je trouve pas ça très très à droite
il s’agit d'une triangulation de la part
du président il a pris assez de façon un
peu comme ça violente une réforme qui
était à droite en disant mais puisque
c'est la vôtre vous allez la voter je
pense que on aurait pu être quelque
chose différemment oui et non oui non
parce que finalement on n'est jamais
mieux servi que par soi-même donc la
droite tu aurais pu dire ben non on va
l'interpréter différemment et on aurait
peut-être eu moins de violence mais bon
c'est des négociation ils ont fait
beaucoup de changements enfin pour
quelques compromis des compromis qui
ensuite ont été
mis et ont été rejetés par le Conseil
constitutionnel
je voudrais qu'on parle du Conseil
constitutionnel un mot je vous ai fait
la deuxième sujet puisque vous dites la
droite la droite alors beaucoup de gens
disent la gagnante de ce débat c'est
Marine Le Pen
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que dans les sondages
il m'amuse un peu ridicule puisque on
l'a fait présenter contre Emmanuel
Macron qui ne pourra pas se représenter
mais elle gagnerait 55 45 quelque chose
comme ça donc tout le monde dit est
formidable Marine Le Pen à quel talent
elle a rien dit elle a rien fait
elle monte et et alors il y a il y a des
gens comme ça qui sont pas éloignés de
de cette droite là de cet extrême droite
je sais pas comment il faut dire qui
sont un peu sceptiques par exemple
Patrick Buisson qui était l'ancien
conseiller de de Nicolas Sarkozy mais
qui est très proche de Zemmour etc
qui fait ce qui dit cette chose très
intéressante dans mon lit il y a
désormais plus étanches pour lui faire
barrage que le Front républicain c'est
le fraude des retraités soit 17 millions
d'électeurs 33% des esprits mais 45% des
votants ont ce gros tour de la
présidentielle donc trois sur quatre ont
rejeté l'ancienne présidente l'URL c'est
à dire qu'en fait oui elle a
on croit les classes populaires et les
jeunes mais c'est pas eux qu'il faut une
majorité
c'est intéressant je trouve après ce
qu'il y a c'est que
on est quand même à 4 ans
donc
c'est quand même intéressant ce que je
trouve intéressant moi c'est surtout ça
a l'air quand même de faire beaucoup
bouger le
personnel politique et on a l'impression
que même chez Renaissance en train de se
dire oui on a beaucoup tapé sur
Mélenchon on a beaucoup tapé sur
l'extrême gauche maintenant il faudrait
qu'on se réveille et qu'on tape sur
l'extrême droite voilà mais visiblement
c'est ils ont très peur mais ce qu'il y
a c'est que effectivement elle elle est
installée dans le paysage politique elle
a plein de de handicap surtout celui de
son nom parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas beaucoup de gens quand même le Pen
c'est aussi son père donc c'est pas très
bon je parle de globalement c'est plein
d'autres défauts mais non
politique de Buisson je sais pas je
trouve intéressant c'est vrai que voilà
il y a un plafond de verre
traités je vois pas pourquoi les
retraités de votre épave pour
l'assemblée on a le chiffre hein
ça peut évoluer très inquiets ils sont
plus acquis que la population les
retraités ils veulent pas trop que ça
bouge mais le problème c'est que les
jeunes sont plus forts dans l'abstention
il y a plus d'abstance
de beaucoup plus fort tout ça pour dire
que tout ça n'est pas quelqu'un
de façon très brève concernant
concernant Marine Le Pen je pense que si
on voyait les choses différemment et si
certains prétendants faisaient un
programme autre que de lutter contre
l'arrivée d'extrême droite on aurait
peut-être des choses plus claires et
peut-être que ça se passerait mieux si
on avait vraiment de vrai programme
se réveiller pour dire on va lutter
contre l'extrême droite qui construisent
un programme et qui aide le président
s'ils ont encore envie je sais pas
plutôt que de ce de partir dans des
combats un peu stupides
tout à l'heure
je pense que la conviction de même le
Macron et que
le plein d'emploi et le meilleur rempart
contre la montée des populismes et
c'est vrai que si vous avez François un
peu plus riche et un peu des salaires un
peu meilleur et des des possibles des
positions de travail meilleure c'est
c'est quelque chose d'important c'est
une position qui évite aussi d'avoir un
vrai projet politique et puis un projet
société
à la dette vous pouvez faire des
investissements non c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas rien il y avait ce qu'on
appelle parce que le problème de le
problème des moyens il faudra qu'on
l'aborde un jour mais quand on a trouvé
une milliards de de dettes voilà donc
c'est vrai que on a pas une liberté
absolue quand même il y avait cette
banane bleue sur en France on avait une
corrélation une similitude entre le vote
Front national à l'époque Front national
et le taux de chômage et là où le
chômage était plus élevé le vote Front
national est donc vous avez donc c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai c'est vrai
aussi des
qui sont très intéressants de passer pas
forcément des régions concernées que
votre front national est plus fort
c'était c'était
de montrer ça de manière très fine on
passe au retour va revenir sur la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
[Musique]
alors
Raphaël validation de la loi à
l'exception de de quelques ce qu'on
appelle des cavaliers sociaux alors la
photo est très belle
alors en fait il y a eu deux décisions
le même jour il y a deux décisions
de la jeunesse
il y a eu deux décisions je pense qu'on
viendra sur celle du riz plus tard
les deux sont très importants alors
concernant en fait la décision sur la
sur la loi alors le Conseil
constitutionnel n'a pas validé la
réforme il a déclaré la loi conforme à
la Constitution
mais globalement ça revient un petit peu
au même alors ce que ce dont on avait
parlé il y a 15 jours je crois sur les
sur les trois éléments les trois moyens
mais finalement la décision était
totalement prévisible contrairement à ce
que beaucoup et contrairement à ce que
beaucoup je savais pas grandir
il y avait pas grand mérite que c'était
c'était quasiment prévisible à
jurisprudence du Conseil consuel était
constante contrairement à ce que disent
d'autres
les cavaliers sociaux ont été censurés
parce qu'il n'avaient rien à faire pour
faire vite
ensuite le l'utilisation de la de la loi
de finance rectificative pour insérer la
réforme la retraite à 74 ans alors ça
c'est un élément intéressant le Conseil
constitutionnel exprime l'idée que
ce n'est pas habituel et encore il y a
ce mot adjectif inhabituel qui est
intéressant mais ce n'est pas
interditel donc il y a aucun il y a
aucune difficulté est-ce que dit le
Conseil considère c'est qu'il ne lui
appartient pas de vérifier l'opportunité
d'utiliser tel ou tel véhicule
législatif alors ça on pourrait alors ça
c'est vrai
47 tirer un le 49.3
c'est-à-dire que la réforme des
retraites normalement c'est c'est de la
loi ordinaire de la loi ordinaire là ça
a été la loi de rectificative le Conseil
constitue dit il ne m'appartient pas de
vérifier l'opportunité alors ça les
constitutionnalistes vont se vont se
vont écrire beaucoup là-dessus
c'est un premier point et puis un
deuxième point pour pour faire très vite
c'est la procédure l'utilisation de du
49-3 alors du 47 ans un certain nombre
de l'article 38 de règlement du Sénat
exactement et donc le Conseil constitut
là aussi a dit la chose suivante toutes
les procédures sont légales enfin je
veux dire il y a aucune
inconstitutionnalité il y a aucune
irrégularité et là où là c'est très
important il dit que
l'accumulation de ces procédures et
revêt un caractère inhabituel et donc là
effectivement on aurait pu se dire bah
si c'est inhabituel ça pourrait porter
atteinte à la sincérité des débats la
clarté du des débats à l'intelligibilité
du débat mais le Conseil Constit dans la
phrase c'est le point 70 de la décision
pour ceux qui veulent aller la lire
le Conseil consiste dit juste après
inhabituel en réponse en réponse à en
réponse aux conditions du débat en
réponse aux conditions du débat et en
fait d'une certaine manière moi je
l'interprète comme étant une réponse de
conseil constitutionnel au blocage je
vais employer le terme même si il pourra
être contesté au blocage des
parlementaires sur la discussion de la
loi en fait en gros les discussions ont
traîné pour différentes raisons pour les
milliers d'amendements notamment
et donc le Conseil consiste à dire voilà
la situation est exceptionnelle et donc
et dans ce questionnaire un constat
politique plus qu'un constat juridique
justement
vu les conditions du débat il a apporté
une appréciation il a apporté une
appréciation politique d'appréciation
alors politique pourquoi pas je vais je
vais le défendre
la Constitution administratif
la conscience de l'espèce voilà il a dit
aux yeux des circonstances la situation
etc
c'est vraiment pour simplifier l'analyse
de la décision vu les circonstances
exceptionnelles je considère que la
procédure n'est pas
contrairement
à la situation ordinaire classique
conscience probable il est probable que
le Conseil constitution aurait eu une
décision différente une appréciation
différente
j'essaie d'expliquer la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel voilà sur ces
trois points importants
[Musique]
vont beaucoup écrire il y a déjà il y en
a des gens qui s'appellent Dominique
Rousseau qui est un qui est un
courcisioniste réputé
qui critique beaucoup la décision et en
disant voilà à chaque fois il
[Musique]
le Premier ministre pardon à un pouvoir
un petit peu plus un peu plus important
et puis le Conseil constitutionnel parce
que c'est lui dont on parle le Conseil
constitutionnel a été créé comme étant
et ça j'insiste comme un organe
politique en 58 chargé de réguler les
pouvoirs chargé d'assurer la régulation
entre le Parlement et l'exécutif et
disons le clairement de protéger
l'exécutif contre les abus potentiels du
Parlement
et donc au départ il a été créé comme
véritable un organe politique et ce
n'est qu'en 1971 où le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est à commencer à
s'émanciper de son de sa création
originale pour devenir une juridiction
chargée d'assurer le respect de la
Constitution par la loi et notamment en
matière de droits fondamentaux c'est la
fameuse décision de 71 associations tout
à fait absolument voilà et en fait ce
qui est intéressant c'est que ceux qui
critiquent aujourd'hui la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel parce que en
vérité alors on peut débattre sur le
plan gelé mais il a d'abord de mon point
de vue mais ça voilà c'est mon point de
vue donner une décision juridique
certains estiment qu'il aurait dû faire
de la politique vous voyez c'est en
fonction en fonction de la en fonction
de l'orientation de la décision du
Conseil on va le critiquer on dit il a
fait de la politique il aurait pas dû
alors là il a fait du droit il aurait dû
faire de la politique bon c'est en
fonction des arguments
pour en revenir à demi-frousseau pour
qui j'ai beaucoup de respect ce que non
non ce que ce qui m'a étonné c'est cette
cette
affirmation péremptoire en disant c'est
voilà c'est juste une petite
rare parce que en plus c'était constant
donc mais ce que pour compléter ce que
dire Raphaël parce que je suis d'accord
que sur le plan juridique c'est assez
imparable
c'est que je pense qu'il y a certains
quand même c'est un coup de griffe du
Conseil constitutionnel
qui sont effectivement un peu plus
politiques puisque il relève quand même
que il y a des ministres qui ont délivré
des estimations
erronées lors des débats parlementaires
ils estiment qu'il y a le fait qu'il y
ait plusieurs
procédures
qui
considère qu'il y a plusieurs procédures
cumulatives pour accélérer la loi mais
que c'est quand même inhabituel et qu'il
dit quand même que normalement on aurait
dû passer par une extraordinaire mais
que ce n'est pas interdit de donc il y a
à la fois un côté un peu politique pour
dire bon c'est quand même un peu moyen
la façon dont ils ont fait mais c'est
constitutionnel mais c'est pour ça qu'il
y a quelque chose quand même de
balancier dans dans ce dans cette
décision qui peut être à la fois et
politique
oui non non mais je dis simplement tous
les jours je suis en train de critiquer
je suis en train d'analyser
en même temps
faire un dôme d'initiative partagée
alors la décision RIP alors RIP 1 parce
qu'il y a il y avait il y a rip 2 il va
y avoir RIP 3 donc la décision RIP 1 a
conduit à une un rejet de la demande de
référendum d'initiative partagée pour
une raison là aussi évidente et on
pouvait parier là-dessus puisque le CET
premier référendum portait sur le fait
que on pouvait pas travailler à plus
jusqu'à 62 ans or ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que le référendum se
porte sur une réforme or au moment et ça
alors ça c'est très technique mais au
moment où le dé ou la loi enfin la
proposition de loi a été déposée l'état
du droit était encore était 62 ans donc
en fait
concrètement ça ne servait à rien et
est-ce qu'il y a pas l'idée comme ça
qu'une
référendum d'initiative partagée ne peut
pas modifier une loi
la Constitution dit bien que un
référendum initiative partagé ne peut
pas alors ça peut porter sur une réforme
mais ne peut pas porter sur l'abrogation
d'une loi qui a été promulguée donc en
tout état de cause
au vu des éléments aujourd'hui un RIP
qui porterait dans la finalité serait
l'abrogation de la de l'âge à 64 ans
pendant un an serait a priori a priori
il recevable en tout cas pour un RIP et
c'est toujours cette cette sorte de
ballon entre la démocratie
représentative et la démocratie
participative ou la démocratie directe
c'est très compliqué
oui on va mettre les deux poids dans la
balance et à savoir qui pour l'instant
on est quand même dans une démocratie
représentative la souveraineté par la
démocratie représentative et le
référendum la démocratie directe les
deux se les deux se valent d'une
certaine manière mais c'est vrai que
pour l'instant c'est
c'est la démocratie représentative qui
est un peu plus protégée
RIP 1 est posé une question qui était
pas qui était pas bonne donc c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont déposé un RIB 2 tout de
suite avant la promulgation de la loi
est un polythologue
que je trouve intéressant dans la
perspective des élections un RIB
donnerait une compétition favorable au
populiste Le Pen est Mélenchon nous
dirait qu'on peut défaire par la rue
ceux que les perles moteurs voulaient
faire la démocratie représentative
peut-on sortir affaibli c'est une
opinion mais
tout à fait
la négation enfin de du travail
parlementaire des élections telles qu'on
les connaît qui fonctionne quand même
après tout pas si mal et que voilà
donner la parole au peuple sur des
choses on sait très bien en plus on l'a
déjà dit 50 000 fois que les gens ne
répondent pas à la question mais ils
voteront oui ou non pour dégager hôtel
président ou telle autre c'est un truc
qui n'a aucun intérêt en tout cas
dans le discours d'Emmanuel Macron
d'hier il y a une petite partie sur la
démocratie justement va réunir le
président du Sénat la présence de
l'assemblée
pour c'est vrai que le problème de
l'abstention est un problème essentiel
mais je pense que là j'espère que tous
ces gens qui passent leur temps à
manifester dans les rues ont quand même
compris que le meilleur moyen c'est
quand même d'aller voter et de voter
contre Macron si Macron les les déçoit
ou de voter pour un tel ou pour une
telle je veux dire donc je pense qu'il y
a peut-être une prise de conscience de
tous ces gens qui sont toujours à hurler
de vociférer et quand on arrive à les
interviewer qui sont pas trop énervés on
dit ok vous n'aimez pas Macron qu'est-ce
qu'on met qui met-on à la place c'est le
grand vide c'est le ils ont voté pour
lui aussi en plus
chercher des motivations
de chacun pour voter parce que vos yeux
comme ça mais assortir le droit de
manifester un permis qui nous dirait oui
j'ai voté non mais voilà à ce moment en
tout cas côté j'ai le droit de râler
mais d'aller râler comme ça sans mettre
les pieds dans un bureau de vote je veux
dire c'était
que la démocratie est en mauvaise santé
les gens s'assoit dessus et à
l'Assemblée nationale les les
minorités mais quand même bruyante et
très agissante ça soit aussi sur les
démocraties je veux dire donc on a vu
c'est dramatique en tout cas les les qui
viennent et moi qui viennent de votre
passionnant parce que c'est vrai que
personne ne voit clairement ce qui peut
se passer il risque d'y avoir voilà des
surprises
qui nous attendent on va voir dans 100
jours si on en croit notre président qui
va peut-être avoir déjà ce que comment
comment Elisabeth borne
donne le programme plus précis dans son
jour il nous apprendra peut-être à faire
le plein de notre voiture
les gestes barrières sur l'autoroute
je sais pas si c'était très habile de
faire un parallèle justement avec Notre
Dame
deux choses
qui a fait qui était très fort à
Napoléon oui mais c'était quand même
très bien de dire j'avais dit on le
refait on refait en 4 ans et ça sera
fait ça c'est merveilleux
on est en France où on met 15 ans à
construire une prison alors que dans
n'importe quel autre pays c'était en
deux ans là une cathédrale magnifique et
millénaire et reconstruite bravo bravo
la France bravo Macron
la raison merci à tous merci à tous les
quatre merci et on se retrouve très vite
parce que il y a beaucoup de choses
encore à dire merci
[Musique]